it is a statement of fact Alec Baldwin
killed that
woman anyway he also shot a guy he
killed her and then hit the guy behind
her yeah so this is the big news though
he's being recharged again and I got to
be honest I'm actually going to defend
Alec baldwi a little bit on this one it
is kind of crazy that they're like going
after him again yeah who's who's
charging him uh I think it's it's New
Mexico uh yeah grand jury well gr jury
indicted but it's the special prosecutor
K morsy and Jason Lewis how come he's
not protected under under uh double
jeopardy I I don't think he was tried I
think if if if you're found not guilty
but to be fair actually like maybe this
is what he deserves there there there
have been a lot of people especially
people on the right saying we should not
let prosecutors just keep doing this
like if they if they run you through the
charges and the charges fall off you're
done but I'm kind of like yeah yeah hold
on jce mlet should get charged like a
prosecutor letting the bad guy go does
not mean we should be like oh well I
guess you got away with it right dep so
yeah I don't know man I I air on the
side of less it just depends on the situ
I I agree that a prosecutor letting bad
guys go on purpose over and over again
is a problem but well I fear that Alec
Baldwin has killed and if he is let out
he will kill
again yeah his interactions with people
in the public are uh like when he just
like did he slam someone against the
door or whatever and punch someone sh
like punch shove but I'm only I'm only
mostly kidding I want be I want to be
clear I am mostly kidding mostly I don't
really think there's a strong
probability Al Bal kills on but I do
believe that there is a probability that
he does not that it's a great one but
it's higher than the average person
because we know he's got a short temper
and I think when you look at the data of
this of this when you the data when you
look at the evidence in this case I I
think it's greater than chance that he
intentionally killed this woman I think
it's greater than chance he had come on
guys we've been over this so many times
but I know a lot of people don't know
the story let me let me let me give you
a version of events assuming I'm the
prosecutor
okay I'm not going to give you an actual
prosecutorial breakdown because I'm not
a prosecutor but I'm going to say this
I'm not going to give you the media's
version I'm not going to be nice to this
man let me tell you a story Alec Baldwin
the producer and financier of a film was
having disputes with his staff who were
upset over pay and safety he had
numerous meetings with them he had a
dinner scheduled with the woman in
question the victim who died some point
while on set Alec bald was having an
argument with her because she kept
telling him what to do but was not the
director she's a cinematographer Alec
Baldwin expressed in an interview his
frustration over this in one of these
scenes he was drawing a weapon pointing
it at her and pulling the
trigger he did just that firing a live
round through her chest killing her and
striking The Man Behind her it was later
found that Baldwin had live ammunition
in his gun belt he is not supposed to
have live ammunition on his person but
he did live ammunition was not only on
his person but was in the weapon that he
pointed at the woman pulled the trigger
killing her he later lied and said he
did not pull the trigger now does that
sound like an accident to you no where
did where did where did the ammunition
come from did he put it there or did
they did come from the prop now on Cross
examination I'm sure good good defense
will ask a witness where did the ask
Alec where where did the ammunition come
from which says I don't know and my
response as a prosecutor would be
like I don't think it is a reasonable
defense the live bullets I had in my gun
belt that was loaded into my gun that I
pointed at a woman pulled the trigger
and killed her and then went but I have
no idea where those bullets came from
who loaded the gun did he load it cuz if
he loaded it the armor but which is um
what was her name um now of course it is
important to break this down because
this is how criminal Criminal Courts
work I think the armor handed it to the
assistant director who handed it to Alec
Baldwin and said hot this is the
importance gun he said cold gun this is
the importance of Defense if a
prosecutor says Alec Baldwin had live
ammunition on his person fact in his gun
belt fact was he supposed to have no
there should be no live ammunition here
the gun was loaded with live ammunition
he pointed the gun pulled the trigger
and killed her ladies and gentlemen this
man did it intentionally it's murder and
they're charging with involuntary
manslaughter now of course the defense
would then say where did the bols come
from did you load the gun why were you
pointing the gun to break down those
points as to why it really happened that
being said it is a fact he was feuding
with this woman he was in disputes over
over uh issues on set involving my
understanding was pay and
security this woman who was frustrating
him he then shoots and kills did I heard
that they were shooting with the gun
like they were shooting target they're
going on the back and shooting can
according to other people that work on
idea the idea that you would use a live
gun in a in a movie like that I mean
there's all kinds of prop houses and and
you know using a gun that you were just
actually shooting target prac that's oh
is it confirmed that they were using the
same gun Alec had on him that's what I'm
asking I'm not I don't know for sure I
heard that according to crew and Cass
that they would go out after work and
shoot at can's out back so there was
live am ammunition on set which there
was not supposed to be any live
ammunition on set my guess here is that
Alec intentionally fantasized about
killing Helena Hutchins he pointed his
gun at her which he thought was empty
was was blank and was pretending to
shoot her by pulling the trigger just
out of like fantasy cuz he was so angry
at her and then someone on the set's
like yo I'm going to frame this piece of
garbage I'm GNA put bullets in his gun
and see what
happens I mean not my opinion is that he
did it on purpose The Perfect Crime I
mean I'm not kidding The Perfect Crime
oh no I was just doing a movie and the
gun that I had that was loaded with
bullets that I had on my gun
belt like I I mean I gotta be honest man
if this wasn't a movie set this guy
whoever like if Alec ball was on the
street and he was like someone else
handed me the gun they'd be like what
someone else handed me the gun told me
to point it at him the the the the woman
that got shot she told me to do it
they'd be like he paid me 100 Grand to
do it like why did you do it cuz he was
paying me like that's the same reason
that did it in the movie sir you shot
woman yeah but she told me to over and
over again how did the bullets get in
the gun I don't know someone else handed
to me sir you have the bullets on you
no idea all just hand it to me and I let
it all happen he was the producer one of
The Producers it was really his
responsibility to check everything I
mean him him blindly trusting the armor
and the ad is like tell you I don't
believe that I just don't believe it for
a second I don't know what happened and
what didn't happen but I know that uh
you know I'm convinced that there
there's enough evidence to have a have a
a trial but I think it should be a
murder
trial uh they're getting him an
involuntary manslaughter and the premise
there is basically like like he was
irresponsible with a gun and because
he's the producer of the film he has
more responsibility over who's AR
loading and everything you know they
only charge what they think they can
prove so I mean even even if someone
agrees with you they have to be able to
prove it yeah without without a shadow
of a doubt I don't think murder is on
the table because there's just unknowns
I think murder's on the table easily I
don't know he was handed the gun it
wasn't like he loaded it if he loaded it
that's one
thing I suppose the argument then
is a imagine a scenario where a guy
shoots and kills a woman and it's like
we can't charge him with murder because
someone else gave him the gun it's like
no you charged them as an
accomplice yeah but did he know there
were bullets in it he pointed a gun at a
person and shot them yeah but now we now
we get to the circumstance it's a
movie Why okay Fair Point fair point
there was a circumstance in which he
should be showing off the weapon why did
he have bullets on
him they were supposed to be blank and
they' been people were scattering them
in with
then I think it's fair to say they need
to investigate as to where the bullets
came from who bought them who brought
them in and they need to trace from
point A to point B but my my issue with
this is that you've got motive you've
you've got motive opportunity and
possession of the ammo and the weapon I
don't understand how it's like okay fine
Fair Point that they're like I don't
know if we can prove it because on a
movie set that just means the Perfect
Crime oh yeah you want to get away with
it do it on a movie set because then
everyone's going to be like even if
you've got the bullets you've got the
gun you're angry at the person you're
screaming at him and then you shoot him
well it was on a movie set that's the
reason he was the producer too cuz he
set it all up like to your point it's
his job to do it it's his job to do it
that way in which she could get away
with it I don't go that far some people
argue that this woman helina Hutchins
was working on a child predator
documentary and then she gets hired for
this film and nah that's that's that's
way too circuitous but the issue
actually is quite simple Alec Balden
wanted to make a movie he's a very
hot-headed guy he's hit people before he
screams at his daughter we know he's got
a temper he had a motive he was fighting
with the staff there were problems on
set they were threatening to like walk
off I think I could be wrong it's been a
long time since we covered this and he
ends up having a meeting with her at
dinner apparently in an interview He was
discussing how she kept frustrating him
by telling him what to do despite the
fact she's not the director so he's
angry with her she's causing him
problems he's a hotthead this is a
pattern of behavior he's had in the past
violent outbursts he has the mean to
kill her the means to kill her he has
the opportunity to do so he was found
with the bullets and he and he lied
about pulling the
trigger so I mean
like I I I kind of feel like you line up
all those circumstances and at the the
lightest you can get with it is a
conspiracy to Comm commit murder but he
was handed the gun someone else brought
the bullets handed him the bullets put
the bullets in his gun belt okay he was
framed somebody wanted her dead and
framed him murder somebody wanted Alec
to kill somebody so that he would go to
jail that's what I'm getting out of this
Al Baldwin's been doing action movies
for decades and and this is the thing
about murder we talked about this when
the story first broke here's a guy who's
been on set for decades handling weapons
and in this one instance I like you know
I I look I'll put it this way a guy is
in the street and he gets into a fight
and he defends himself and and ends up
killing one of the guys we say it's
self-defense he didn't know what's going
to happen let's say it's mutual
combat they're actually is in law if you
are a trained fighter you can get
aggravated uh uh modifications to your
charges because you know what you're
doing can cause this harm so in the
instance that Alec Baldwin's a who
has no idea what's going on and fires a
gun and goes Whoopsie Daisy
sure but then you have to you also have
to mention to the jury and to the people
you you expect me or a reasonable person
to believe that a man who's been working
in films and action movies with guns for
decades did not know about these is
issues okay then we're dealing with
negligent homicide it's murder because
of gross negligence on the part of Alec
Baldwin not involuntary manslaughter
which I don't know what the laws are in
New Mexico if they actually have those
those uh uh if they actually have that
in their in in their codified in their
statutes yeah I kind of I'm looking
where Phil's at right now I think you
make a lot of sense they charge with
what they think they can get and it's
pretty obvious that he was resultant in
her death meaning it was an involuntary
manslaughter at
minimum I wonder what they're going to
do with the armor did they charge the
armorer and the assistant director for
handing him the weapon they charge the
armor so I mean it's it's it's wild to
me that the precedent being set here is
actually like you can get away with
murder on a movie set but but but I'll
be completely fair I I don't think most
people real realize this the majority of
premeditated murder is never solved yeah
never man like I got to tell you anybody
who's ever actually had to deal with
police and like ser serious crimes
understands Ain no solving any of this
your car gets stolen sorry have a nice
day your car's gone Chop Shop gone
products gone seal numers all gone
there's no there's no searching for it
the cops are going to be like well write
it down and have a good day your car is
that's it it's over the likelihood they
find your car not going to happen are
these airpods useful for that kind of
thing people are air poding their stuff
air tags air tags tracking their materal
I mean but they are useful that means
you can you can find it but criminals
use airs tags to track you I mean are
you going to go there to wherever the
car is you don't know where the car want
to it's like the other thing too is it
what tells you that airpods are moving
or air tags are moving with you if it's
not yours so one thing that criminals do
is they'll they'll put a tag on your car
they'll they'll when they'll be out in
the city there will be a car that's
really really nice they'll stick an air
tag on it and then they can see you know
let's say you're let's say you're at a
really high-end restaurant or a casino
and you're you're driving uh super
high-end car of some sort something like
you know $80,000 $100,000 car they're
GNA tag your car wait for you to go home
and they're gonna know where you live
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net